there was a woman who showed up in
loudoun county where a lot of this is
being focused showed up to her school
board
and mentioned that her daughter asked
this white woman the daughter white girl
asked her mother if she was born evil
because of the color of her skin my
children are now in private school and
are thriving we had specifically moved
into based out of lcps due to the swift
and uncompromising political agenda of
superintendents williams ziegler and sc
and the school board
that have forced upon us first it was in
early spring of 2020 when my
six-year-old somberly came to me and
asked me if she was born evil because
she was a white person something she
learned in a history lesson at school
then you kept the schools closed for a
year and a half despite the science
indicating that it was safe for kids to
return and now you've covered up a rape
then arrested humiliated and falsely
accused her parents of being domestic
terrorists i wish i could return my kids
to lcps private schools expensive and i
want my kids to be able to walk home
from school with their friends in their
own community i refuse to allow you to
destroy our schools they are not your
schools they are our schools you all
should be ashamed and you should have
the moral courage to admit you are wrong
and step down
preach sister absolutely right such
moral clarity and she's very articulate
as well
this matters much more to americans than
tax cuts do
i like tax cuts i don't like paying a
lot of taxes i want to pay the lowest
amount of taxes that i am legally
obligated to pay
okay but if my taxes go up a little bit
i'm like probably not even going to
notice
right or i'll notice a little bit and
it's too bad and
we won't go out to dinner a few times
that year and but it'll be fine you know
what i really care about
my kids being taught that they're born
evil because of the color of their skin
you know what i really care about my kid
being pumped full of insane sexual
confusion that could ruin his life that
bothers me i can't send my kids to
public school
that bothers me
i wish i could send my kids to public
school
but i can't i went to public school my
wife went to public school we met in
public school
i have no problem with that
i really like public schools
where i liked them
and even then our schools were very very
liberal but
they weren't mutilating kids genitals
all right they weren't pumping their
heads full of this racial nonsense
that says you're evil if you're a white
person
that's a big problem it's a big problem
for people when you are trying to reach
your fitness goals it can really help to
have world-class instructors
choreographing classes music from your
favorite artists and a community of
hundreds of thousands of people who can
give you that extra push now that's
generally hard to bring into your house
i don't know how big your house is but
it's hard to bring those hundreds of
thousands of people to your home
echelon is the affordable way to get the
workout equipment and the workout
community and the instructor's
motivation right in the comfort of your
own home echelon's fitness app provides
you thousands of live and on-demand
classes with great
music with echelon you can work out
anytime day or night and crush
your fitness goals echelon's full range
of affordable workout equipment
including stationary bike smart rowers
sleek fitness screens
and the auto folding treadmill are all
connected to provide the echelon
experience around the clock classes for
the family including full body workout
programs that keep you coming back one
membership covers a family of five right
now for a limited time our listeners get
up to eight hundred dollars off msrp to
get this exclusive podcast discount text
knolls to 81 81 81 text knowles k wles
281 8181 to get up to 800 off msrp that
is knowles kwles 281
one i like to think hopefully look
hopefully i sell some more blank books i
can afford to send my kid to private
school even though by the way a lot of
the private schools are pretty bad too
or maybe we can homeschool
i hope we have the resources to do that
when the time comes i don't know what i
do know is that for most americans they
don't really have the resources to do
that or it's very very difficult for
them to
focus on that
let's let's focus a little bit more on
that i know it's a little politically
edgier and riskier to talk about things
like race and sex
than it is to talk about tax cuts and
socialism and government spending
but those are the issues that matter to
people those are the issues where the
left has gained a huge advantage and
it's deeply unjust and it's wrong for
everybody and you should fight back
especially when the people who are
peddling this have have nothing but
contempt for their constituents there
was a school board
a woman just another woman
all women of all shapes and colors and
sizes and demographics showing up to
these school boards to say don't teach
my kids this crap
one of the school board presidents
actually uh
she used a phrase similar to let's go
brandon but the right we use the kind of
nice devulgarized version this woman
just used
the the
insults and the swear words themselves a
california school board president
was listening to this woman
opposing the vaccine mandates
for the little kids
who are at very very low risk of
coronavirus
who
really
should i think the parents should be
allowed to make these medical decisions
for themselves
and the school board president heard her
out then cut her off the earliest chance
she got and then said f you lady my name
is lauren napoli and i am here as a
concerned parent to urge you to be the
first school to say no mandates for our
children let our children leave our
children alone let them be kids and
enjoy one another let them breathe again
and smile again emailing and calling
like you say isn't going to help choose
your own path scott choose your own path
that was very rude to you to say your
parents are selfish and you say what's
next thank you your time's up
you can hear we bleep to that obviously
but you can hear it
pretty pretty clearly because we're a
family show
you see the school board members
when they're talking about little kids
education they can use whatever nasty
language they want but we here on this
show we try to keep it a little a little
more wholesome
these people hold you in contempt they
hate you they think that you're a racist
an a phobe an a hateful bigoted person
they think you're born evil
whether you're white or whether you're
not white but you agree with
conservatives then you just sort of
become white you know then
i don't know you're like that guy that
the lincoln project sent to
to the terry to the glenn young event
rather
maybe you look black or like a some
other minority but you're a white
supremacist if you support these
conservatives or you show up to these
school boards or you say don't don't
tell little johnny that he's a really
little jane you're an evil or don't
judge people on the color of their skin
you're an evil deplorable bitter
clinging bible-thumping idiot rube who
just needs to die off
and make room for the good better
americans hey there youtube ring that
bell please please i i want to be polite
please ring the bell subscribe
theoretically you should get
notifications when you do that you
probably still won't but that's that's
okay that's fine you can also go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe maybe leave a five star
review
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you